It's no secret that Hollywood has a habit
of playing fast and loose with the truth
in the name of entertainment, and we all
know that the words 'based on real events'
are really code for 'we made 90% of the
plot up to make it more interesting.'
There's a long list of movies based on so-called
'true stories' that have been significantly
spiced up for the silver screen, from Catch
Me If You Can to The Texas Chainsaw Massacre.
The Revenant starring Leonardo DiCaprio
is another good example. Released in 2015
to critical acclaim, the film tells the
story of American frontiersman Hugh Glass,
who gets horrifically mauled by
a grizzly bear before going on an
epic journey to wreak his revenge on the
men who abandoned him in the aftermath.
It sounds like textbook Hollywood hyperbole,
and the Revenant certainly took some serious
liberties with the truth. In fact,
outside of the bear-mauling itself,
almost every major plot point in
the entire film is utter nonsense.
But here's the funny thing. While it's
absolutely true that Hollywood had its
wicked way with Hugh Glass' story -
if anything, the fictional retelling
was actually significantly *less* epic
than the real events of his life. I mean,
they didn't even mention the part where he was
forced to become a pirate, or the bit where he
watched his friend burned alive with slivers of
superheated pine. And no, I'm making that up.
This is the story of Hugh Glass - a tale
so incredible Hollywood toned it
down to make it more believable.
We don’t know a whole heap about Hugh’s early
life, but he was probably born sometime around
1783 near Philadelphia. These days we know him as
a famous frontiersman and bare-knuckled boxer of
bears, but when he first pinged into existence
on history's radar, he was actually a sailor.
His ship was attacked by pirates somewhere off
the coast of what is now Texas in 1819. Most of
the crew were killed, but after acquitting
himself particularly well in the fight,
Glass was given a choice - ally with the pirates,
or join the rest of his crew leaking blood and
guts onto the deck. After deliberating for
several microseconds, Glass chose the former.
As is the case with most bold career changes,
becoming a pirate wasn't easy. For one thing
there was a lot more raping and pillaging than
Glass was used to, and despite having a solid
work ethic he never really took to it. At what
I like to think of as the equivalent of his
first annual appraisal, Glass' new boss - the
notorious pirate Jean Lafitte - was not pleased.
As punishment for his perceived crimes,
Glass was set to stand trial before
Lafitte beside another condemned crew member.
Both men knew their fate would be a long walk
from a short plank, so they made a run for
it (which quickly became a swim for it).
They were 2 miles out to sea at the time, but
somehow both made it to shore alive, where they
set about living off the land, avoiding search
parties, and trying not get eaten by cannibals -
they were in Karankawa territory, a Native
American tribe well known for their predilection
for human flesh. I should point out that there’s
no evidence the Karankawa were cannibals - the
rumour seems to have been started by Spanish
colonists, and it stuck. Still, Glass and his
buddy didn't know that, and quite understandably
they had no intention of putting it to the test.
Keeping a low profile, the two men headed north
in search of friendly settlements. 700 miles
later in what is now Kansas, they were captured by
members of the Pawnee tribe. On the bright side,
the Pawnee weren't cannibals - on the shite side
- they *did* practise ritual human sacrifice.
Soon after they were caught, Glass' travelling
companion was stripped naked and burnt at the
stake. As he died, his writhing body was stabbed
repeatedly with burning splinters of pinewood.
Glass would have been next, but as the
tribesmen began to prepare him for the ceremony,
he reached into his pocket and produced
a vial of a red ore called cinnabar,
which he presented to the tribe's chief with
a deep bow, and awaited his fate with dignity.
Cinnabar was highly prized by the Pawnee - and the
chief was so impressed with the gift - as well as
the gravity and respect with which it had been
given - that not only did he spare Glass' life,
he accepted him into the tribe. It's thought
that Glass went on to live with the Pawnee
for several years, and there's a pretty
good chance his later feats of survival
were made possible at least in part
by the things he learned from them.
He left the tribe sometime in the early 1820s,
making his way to St. Louis, where he responded
to an advert to join the recently-formed (and
soon to be world famous) Rocky Mountain Fur
Company. The company, founded by William Ashley
and Andrew Henry, was seeking tough men to join a
2000 mile expedition up the Missouri River to
the recently established Fort Henry, which was to
serve as a base for fur trapping both on the river
itself and in the Rocky Mountains to the west.
The men who joined that now legendary
expedition would come to be known as
Ashley's 100, and they were some of
the toughest men ever to have lived,
including some now-household names
like Jedediah Smith and Jim Bridger.
Progress up the river in two large boats was
slow but steady until an attack by members of
the Arikara tribe left 14 of Glass' new
colleagues dead and many more injured.
Glass himself was shot in the leg during the
skirmish, and the men were forced back downriver.
Founders, William Ashley and Andrew Henry had
sunk a huge amount of capital into the expedition,
and returning home empty handed simply wasn't an
option if the fledgling company was to survive.
With the Missouri deemed too dangerous, the
group split into two - one, led by Ashley,
went west in search of beaver and immediate
profits, while the other, led by Henry and
including Hugh Glass, went north to Fort Henry
on foot in the hope of bypassing the Arikara.
The plan was only partially successful,
and the group ended up in several more minor
skirmishes with the locals. But for Glass,
the biggest danger wouldn't come from
muskets and tomahawks, but teeth and claws.
He was out hunting one day when he heard
a sudden commotion in the undergrowth.
He turned to see a massive shape
hurtling towards him at full speed,
and he had just enough time to raise his
rifle and fire before the creature was on him.
If you've seen the Revenant, you'll
know exactly what happens next - Glass
had inadvertently disturbed a mother
grizzly bear and her cubs. Grizzlies
aren’t exactly friendly at the best of times,
but a mother with her young is the dictionary
definition of overprotective. Glass was
mauled to within an inch of his life.
The way the story's usually told, he managed
to stab the bear to death during the struggle,
but the truth is, an adult grizzly in full-on
attack mode is practically invincible once it
gets up close, and chances are it
was Glass' companions - alerted by
his screams - who brought the bear
down with sustained musket fire.
To begin with, they thought Glass was dead
too, until someone noticed his chest was
still rising and falling. Amazingly, death was
not yet calling, but one of his legs was broken
and his back was so badly lacerated that his
ribs were visible beneath his bloodied skin.
It was obvious to everyone that Glass wouldn't
last. So they made him as comfortable as they
could, strapped him to a makeshift
stretcher, and continued on their way.
They didn't get far - Glass was a dead
weight, severely hampering their pace
in this treacherous place - they were
still in Arikara territory after all.
With little other choice, Henry offered a
reward of $80 - the equivalent of a couple
of grand in today's money - to any
men who would stay behind with Glass
in his final hours to give him a proper
Christian burial. Two men stepped forward.
The first was a veteran trapper named John
Fitzgerald, and the second was a 17-year
old rookie identified only as 'Bridger' - some
historians believe this was probably Jim Bridger,
who would go on to become one of the most
famous frontiersmen of the Old American West.
Fitzgerald and Bridger no doubt assumed they
were going to make some easy cash - Glass was
at death's door, with the only sign he hadn't
already been invited inside for tea and hobknobs
with the Grim Reaper himself being the occasional
flicker of his eyes. But day after day went by,
and while Glass certainly wasn't getting
any better, he wasn't dead either.
Fitzgerald and Bridger were getting twitchy.
Nobody had expected Glass to live this long,
and $80 was beginning to look like
inadequate compensation for their
dangerous task. After 5 days went
by with no sign of Glass expiring,
they decided to act. They took his rifle,
knife, and flint, and left him for dead.
The two men reached Fort Henry just a couple
of days after the rest of the group and duly
confirmed that Glass was dead and buried, safe
in the knowledge that there was no way he could
possibly come back and prove them wrong (I'm
guessing they'd never seen the Lion King).
Glass, meanwhile, had woken from his stupor, still
alive but in Dire Straits. He managed to splint
his broken leg, but the rest of his injuries were
beginning to fester and he had no supplies or
survival gear. Pretty much the only thing he *did*
have was a burning desire to get his revenge on
the men who'd robbed him and left him to die alone
in the wilderness hundreds of miles from home.
They say that the journey of a thousand
miles starts with a single step,
but that assumes one can actually
walk. Hugh Glass' long road back to
civilization most likely started with a
3 inch scrabble and a very loud scream.
Most people would have given up there
and then. He was 300 miles from the
nearest friendly settlement - a small trading
post called Fort Kiowa - and on the journey
there was a whole host of hazards. But
Hugh Glass was not 'most people.' He was
an ex-pirate who'd survived being shot in the
leg and mauled by a bear, and who'd learned to
survive in the wilds of North America from
the people who'd lived there for millennia.
Day by day, he dragged himself onwards, drinking
water from streams and mashing passing insects
into his mouth for nourishment. After about a week
of this pitiful existence he stumbled - across a
pack of wolves feasting on a buffalo calf. He
waited patiently for the predators to eat their
fill, then dragged himself over to the carcass.
It was a find that very probably saved his life.
He set up a makeshift camp nearby and gorged
on buffalo meat until his strength returned.
As he slowly recuperated, he allowed
maggots to proliferate in the worst of
his wounds. That might sound
like a truly terrible idea,
but maggot therapy is actually an FDA approved
biotreatment for various ailments even today.
In Glass' case, the writhing yellow larvae ate
away his rotting flesh, preventing gangrene.
He was still badly wounded, but when
he set out again for Fort Kiowa,
he was able to move far more freely. When
he hit the Missouri River soon afterwards,
he either borrowed a skin boat from a friendly
tribe of Lakota, or possibly fashioned his own,
depending on which source you read. Either way,
the next leg of his journey was significantly
smoother than the first - he simply floated
down river all the way to Fort Kiowa,
arriving approximately 6 weeks after his
date with destiny at the paws of the grizzly.
After this epic journey back to civilization
and safety, you might think Hugh Glass would
have put his feet up for a bit. But while
most of his physical injuries had healed,
the mental ones had not. The men who had
abandoned him to die were still out there
somewhere living their lives as if nothing had
happened. Glass was determined to put that right.
After just a couple of days at the fort,
he heard about a new expedition heading back
up the Missouri in the direction of Fort Henry,
where he assumed Fitzgerald and Bridger would
be waiting. Glass signed up immediately.
It turned out to be an eventful trip. The
expedition was only due to go as far as a group
of villages about halfway between Fort Kiowa and
Fort Henry, and so Glass planned to hike the rest
of the way on his own. The day after he split with
the other members of the group, they were ambushed
by Arikara and every single one of them was
slaughtered. Glass had a run-in with the Arikara
himself, only narrowly escaping with his life
after warriors from a rival tribe came to his aid.
When he finally arrived at Fort Henry after 6
weeks on the river and a month of solo hiking,
instead of an epic showdown with the men who'd
wronged him, he found... absolutely nothing. Fort
Henry had been abandoned, and, according to a note
he found pasted to the door, relocated nearby.
In the end, he strode into Fort Henry 2.0
more than 4 months after he'd been mauled
by the grizzly. The men stationed at the
fort must have thought they were seeing
a ghost - after all, they had it on good
authority that Glass was dead and buried.
Not our friend Bridger though - he knew exactly
what he was seeing: a big fucking problem.
I think everyone can relate to that horrible
sinking feeling you get when someone catches
you in a lie. I’m guessing Bridger felt it too,
only worse - because *his* lie was also pointing
a gun in his face. In the end, he needn’t
have worried. Glass was out for revenge,
but he was also a reasonable man. Bridger
seemed to be genuinely remorseful for his crime,
and, after pleading his case to Glass, the
grizzlied frontiersman ultimately decided that,
as the older man, the real
blame lay with Fitzgerald.
Unfortunately, Fitzgerald had left
the camp more than a month earlier
to join up with the army at Fort
Atkinson in what is now Nebraska.
By this point winter had set in, and it was a full
two months before Glass could set off in pursuit.
After another long hike and yet another deadly
run-in with the Arikara, Glass finally made it
to Fort Atkinson, where he found himself
face to face with John Fitzgerald. Glass
was a simple man. He didn't embark on some long
speech or ask Fitzgerald to explain his actions.
He simply pulled out his gun, levelled it at
Fitzgerald's head, and... did absolutely nothing.
Just at the moment he'd been about to pull
the trigger, a nearby army officer pointed
out that murdering a member of the American
military in cold blood was a capital offence.
In other words, if Glass shot
Fitzgerald, he'd be hanged immediately.
It must have taken a huge amount
of willpower to lower his weapon,
but lower it he did. He left Fitzgerald
with a parting promise - if he ever
left the protection of the army, Glass
would find him, and he would kill him.
Because he had a very particular set of skills,
skills he’d acquired over a very long career.
Glass would live on the American frontier for
the rest of his life, trapping, trading, hunting,
and exploring. He was a veteran of many battles
with the various tribes whose lands the United
States of America was slowly claiming for its
own, but it was in 1833 at the approximate age
of 50 that his luck finally ran out. He and two
fellow trappers were ambushed by a large party
of Arikara braves while crossing a frozen river.
They were all shot, robbed, and finally scalped.
In the years since, Hugh Glass' remarkable story
has quite rightly achieved legendary status.
But as with many legendary tales, there's a fairly
good chance some of this one isn't true. Much of
what we know about Glass' life comes from sources
that are hard to trust entirely, and rumour has it
Glass himself was fond of telling tall tales,
particularly when they concerned himself.
Exactly where we should draw the line between
fact and fable is up for debate, but one thing's
for certain: even if only one tenth of the
stories told about Hugh Glass are true,
he was undeniably one of the most remarkable men
- and greatest survivors - ever to have lived.
Thanks for watching.